hey omi hey fool hey watto hey hey curl
hey bro what's up blood hey wood hey
that's it come here
prison's a culture clash man there's all
kinds of different people that get
caught up in california they come here
for vacation and end up on probation hey
my name's fabian alamar
and i'm here to answer some questions
about prison
prisoners eat what they're given in
ciao and uh it's not that good sometimes
there's certain days that are good but
most of the time it's like
mystery meat cosmic slop scary yucky
you might get a sweet and sour but it's
really sour you know
it's not good you make sopas a lot of
spreads but once you hit the pin that's
in the county jail once you hit the pin
depending on how you're living you might
get some order some chiloros and
packages
you get that chelorio and you get the
tortillas and beans
and you got yourself a good cook like my
boy pantera he's a good cook
you're in that's how i kept my weight
you know
it's a myth man it's a myth no one's
going after you like that
it's all like hollywood makes you
believe that it's this
like oh you dropped the soap and you
just leave it there and like you don't
want to pick it up
that's weird like why would you do that
get that you bought it or they gave it
to you
go wash yourself with it pick it up
stupid don't be dumb
you know like white drop the soap that's
stupid that's some like myth you know i
dropped it so plenty of times ain't
nobody ran up on me
but i don't do it on purpose no it just
slipped man
it slipped are there a lot of fights in
prison
come on bro of course there's fights
there's knife fights there's fist fight
there's riots
there's all kinds of going on in prison
yeah here's here's my advice
keep your ears open keep your eyes
peeled
and shut your mouth and just mind your
own business
you'll live long they were like hey
you're that guy that does the youtube
videos
you're that solo strike guy so it
surprised me to be in prison
to be in a county jail and in prison i'm
telling you i got on a bus the driver of
the bus
knew who i was he's like hey you're
still going to do those i'm getting in
i'm shackled up
are you still going to do those funny
videos
and i looked at him like this is not the
time to ask me like tom shackled up i
could i'm taking baby steps like
baby steps in like i'm like this and
then we're all chained up like it's
and he wants to ask me i'm still going
to do those funny videos
nobody wants to be famous in prison
that's that's a no-no
famous in prisons mean you know what
that means
you got money and i don't got money like
that
i just because i give you a soap i don't
mean i'm rich once you've done enough
time
you become a macgyver on all kinds of
stuff hey there's a lot of five stars
that make all kinds they're like that
the
crazy gadgets they make frames
jerseys now they make jerseys and like
all kinds of like
your favorite football team baseball
team whatever soccer team
with your number and your name in the
back i mean they're getting real
creative man these guys need their own
store
no matter what yard you go to whether
it's a low level or a high level
no matter what you're you're taken away
from society you're you're taking away
from your family and your freedom and
uh it's not a fun place to be in it's
not fun no matter what
you're still in prison change your life
and fix your face
you